June 21st 2018 Greta tunberg Saint Greta
of the Blessed sailboat tweets out a top
climate scientist is warning that
climate change will wipe out all of
humanity unless we stop using fossil
fuels over the next five years Greta has
apparently deleted this tweet I'm just
going to look at my calculations here
it's in 2018 now it's 2023 carry the 7.
oh
it's been five years we are approaching
the end of the world aren't we and yet
the behavior of people might seem to
predict the end of the world but the
natural facts of the earth seem just
fine
another Doomsday Prophecy has not come
true as all the rest of the Doomsday
prophecies have not come true